hey I'm Kennedy for recent EDTV hello
and today we're streaming live from
reason studio in Los Angeles I'm talking
with Timothy Taylor he's the author of
the sounds of capitalism he's a UCLA
professor of musicology and he's tracked
music and advertising for nearly a
century and how its uses have aligned
with the marked rise in consumerism over
the years
so welcome professor Taylor thank you go
bro all right so obviously it starts
with radios infancy and figuring out
that music was a cheap and easy way to
reach the masses how did it all start
well there was music used in advertising
before which I don't look at in the book
but you know cheap music and medicine
shows and you know so people were kind
of used to that you to the idea that
music could be used to sell something
and then when radio comes along it
starts as something that hobbyist did
sort of like in their eyes of a personal
computer so it took a little while to
catch catch on but in the 20s it finally
started to catch on and then the
advertising industry which was used to
print didn't quite know what to do with
sound yeah
and it took them awhile to figure out
what to do with it or what to do with
radio and they were really afraid of a
hard sell of your like radio coming into
your home you know like an ad in this
paper you can just turn the page but
with radio yeah you said that yeah they
wanted they wanted it to feel like a
family member or a friend someone who's
a welcome guest in your home and they
didn't want to offend too many people so
you know balance those early programmers
between classical and jazz that was a
big question what kind of music to use
and what did people want but then what
kind of music would best represent the
product so there's a lot of debates
about classical versus jazz in
particular but there's a lot of
different kind of music that was on the
air in those days and the variety hours
as well like a show a single show that
would try and give you a little bit of
everything yeah that was a solution they
came upon in the late twenties to try to
figure out you know like well dad might
like to listen to jazz but you know
junior might want to listen to like
sports and you know mom might want to
hear you know familiar songs from the
1890s so they they put it all in one
hour long show yeah that's how they
address that problem in casting a wide
net and of course you have the Lucky
Strike hour and
the ever ready hour and the shows that
were named for advertisers how long did
it take before they started blatantly
naming things for companies to sell time
almost from the beginning because in
that era before there was a star system
it wasn't that expensive to put on a
radio show because they weren't paying
stars gazillions of dollars like they do
today so a single company could pay for
the production of an entire program and
then if they were doing that they wanted
their name in the title it's a lot of
famous radio shows that people might
remember or that have been rerun I mean
I grew up on public radio they had you
know they were rerunning old shows but
shows like fibber McGee and Molly that
was actually called the johnson's wax
program with fibber McGee and Molly and
the Jack Benny program was actually you
know the jello program with Jack Benny
because all of these sponsors they
wanted their names you know in the title
and then the names of the musical groups
it would be you know Ipana toothpaste
sponsored a show and their band that
played all the numbers on the show that
was that band was called the Ipana
troubadours that was very common and
they would sell ginger ale and
toothpaste and everything else and then
eventually we got to jingles and we DS
had the first successful jingle yeah in
1926 it didn't really catch on jingles
didn't catch on till later and but it
helps save Wheaties because who a tease
wasn't a brand that was very
particularly well so General Mills in
Minnesota which happened to own a radio
station they thought well you know we
got to be using this radio station for
something so the vertical integration
very early so they sort of cobbled
together a barbershop quartet that sang
a kind of barbershop eyes version of a
popular song from 1919 and that that
song saved Tweety's
but it didn't really catch on to the
extent that people across the country
were thinking mmm you know we could you
know we could write a jingle to know but
they looked at the sales in Minnesota
and thought like how is this happening I
mean they're they're through the roof
yep yeah Wheaties was sort of on the
ropes and the jingle everybody thinks
you know saved Wheaties as you know
which is still around today and it's
interesting to try and figure out
demographics and and who's listening and
how they learn to do that because that
was an evolving process and one of the
things
was you know getting people to send in
letters and then they would go through
and and try and parse the handwriting
and the intelligence of the letter
writer and try and figure out the age
and also the false cancellations yep
yeah they had a number of strategies
because again you know the and the every
time the industry was used to print so
they knew that you know and this
neighborhood in New York City they sold
you know X copies of this magazine
whatever I mean they they they knew they
knew that that was in a wealthy
neighborhood or a poor neighborhood or
whatever but with every tossing they had
no idea I army with radio they had no
idea and so they would do all kinds of
things just to get people to write in
including giving away free products
sponsoring contests and then they'll do
yep
and like as you said you know people
would the network's would say oh you
know this show we're gonna cancel this
show and people are right in and say no
don't cancel the show even though they
had no intention of canceling and so
they just wanted to generate an
emotional response and and it's funny
because jingles were such a huge part of
advertising for so long and who are the
first really successful jingle well er
Chiquita banana it was Pepsi in 1939 two
guys you know famously they walked into
Walter Mack who was a president of Pepsi
and they walked in with a portable
phonograph which existed in that era
yeah and they played a jingle that they
had written based on an old English folk
song which means that the copyright
didn't have to be paid and that became
the norm if you use an existing folk
song and Walter Mack who was always
trying to find ways to catch up with
coca-cola he said you know sold I'll
take it I mean he didn't spend much
money on it and and that era which might
sound surprising to people today but in
that era
you couldn't lease airtime in packages
less than five minutes in other words if
you wanted to get something on the radio
you had to pay for five minutes or more
but here was a 60 second jingle so
Walter Mack found down on the down on
the dumps radio station and I think was
in Newark and they were willing to lease
him 60 seconds of air time and the
jingle proved to be so popular that
other stations started leasing 60 60
seconds of airtime just for that jingle
and this is how we get the 60-second
commercial later the 30-second
commercial it was all because of this
jingle Pepsi Cola hits the spot
which was hugely hugely popular and
inform influential both and it sold that
moved a lot of units and did they use it
for decades and they were already in the
middle of the Cold War's back then which
is really fascinating because there
there are so many signposts throughout
the the Coke Pepsi feud it's a it's
pretty fascinating now what was the
height of the jingle era 50 60s and 70s
and the and then the 80s it starts to
decline but in and those three decades a
jingle composer had virtually unlimited
budgets I mean jingle composer could
write a jingle for you know a quartet of
singers and maybe a 30 piece Orchestra
you know this was before computer
technology allowed data it's you know to
simulate all that with a computer and
they could hire the best studio
musicians in LA New York and you know
they could just do whatever they wanted
and there's a lot of money to be made
and a lot of really great jingle in your
head I mean literally like everyone in
here could probably recite and sing like
15 jingles and it's so much fun to do
and you even say that in your book like
people sit around at dinner parties at
your dinner parties and sing jingles
yeah I mean this is what academics do
you know we can read together and I say
well what are you working on well I'm
running on the look about music and
advertising it's like oh I remember this
tingle do you know is tingle people
would sing me jingles and it was great
that's why you wear headphones wherever
you go
right but you know in the days when no
expense was spared and writing these
jingles you know really great musicians
are ready Herbie Herbie Hancock yeah
Barry Manilow wrote some of the best
angles ever I think and then there's
lots of musicians who are less
well-known but we're still really good
composer yeah Barry Manilow was a huge
jingle composer yeah and then he you
even say in the book that he started
performing a medley of his jingles one
of its most popular songs yeah yeah
before he was a star you know when one
of the ways that he connected with his
audience was to sing jingles cuz he
never everybody knew thank Brent
alright so there were obviously huge
ships and music and advertising after
the Great Depression and during the SEC
world war and post-war and one of the
interesting things you write about is
Freudian advertising and how did that
work with music well were some of the
connections well a strange thing that
that I uncovered in writing this book
was that you know in the movie industry
musicians were always talking about like
music and emotion like what music are we
gonna use to represent the emotions of
what's going on on screen or to you know
I realize what's going on screen or you
know but to somehow represent or portray
what's going on in screen and radio that
wasn't the case at all music was thought
the function music was thought to be to
animate a product you know because
people couldn't see it so you had to use
music to like bring the product to life
somehow and it wasn't really until the
very late 50s early 60s that composer
started to say well wait a minute you
know we can start using the emotional
effect of music also like they do in
films but it took that long yeah which
is really kind of striking it's probably
because of the the hold older holdover
the print mentality you know and
advertising that lasted so long and
interestingly it was all classical
trained composers who are the ones who
were pushing this emotional connection
and I mean you talk about the lag but it
wasn't until 1967 that advertisers
embraced the youth culture which seems
insane I mean why did it take so long
and what was the big shift well the baby
booms kind of kind of forced it but
advertisers are still really reluctant
because they were they were always
afraid to offend anybody so I mean that
rock and roll was dirty and low-class
yeah and they were afraid of offending
you know southern customers you might
want to hear you might not want to hear
black music and commercials so
advertised music always lag behind what
was going on in popular music more
generally and it was the same you know
with the baby boom in youth culture and
when they first started to try to
attract the youth they had no idea that
yes you know I mean some of the
musicians they would talk about you know
what they did to try to attract the
youth culture and it sounds laughable
today it's you know in terms of what
they were doing musically but they they
put it they figured it out pretty
quickly because you know they they knew
that there was money to be to be made
and after a while you know people like
George Martin you know famously produced
the Beatles he was working in
advertising by the early 70s
so when it when it finally happened it
happened but it happened mainly because
the whole baby boom from when I was kind
of a juggernaut so you either had to you
know jump on or get out of the way and
baby boomers have been responsible for
quite a few shifts in music and
advertising including you know the
horrible era of like Bob Seger and
repurposed songs and reach out and touch
someone and the 80s nostalgia and the
Big Chill and all that I mean talk about
the Reagan era and consumerism who is
this height of both the music industry
and the Advertising Age well it's
interesting because during the Reagan
era the jingle started to go on their
way out because during the 80s all these
baby boomers who were used in the 50s
and 60s they started to assume positions
of power in the advertising industry and
they didn't want to hear you know what
they thought was trite or you know sort
of cheesy music and advertising they
want to hear their own music you know
either from the sixties or newer music
so that proved to be you know hugely
effective in helping to continue to
promote American consumer culture which
radio helped to promote you know even
back in the 20s and it was sacred
like you know consumerism was in
consumption was seen as a form of self
creation yeah it became a kind of
patriotic duty you know probably some
people here in the room and who are
viewing remember that after 9/11 you
know George W Bush and Mayor Junie
Giuliani in New York where I was living
at the time they didn't say go out and
serve your country or join the Armed
Forces they said you know go out and
spend money you know like you've got to
support the consumer culture that's what
it was about yeah and and that was you
know this was still at a time where
there was there was economic turmoil but
the idea that the more stuff you had the
happier you would be I mean that's
something that that vein was present
throughout advertising and in music but
it really exploded in the 80s yeah it
did became you know uh you know as I say
a kind of sacred duty of people in this
country to to consume you to have more
and more and more and more so friends of
mine at UCLA have conducted a study
of everyday lives of families here here
in Southern California and one of the
things that they've discovered is that
virtually nobody uses their garage for
their car yeah it's full of stuff and
one of the one of the big things that I
remember as a kid was the Michael
Jackson Pepsi commercials because that
was huge and and you would wait like
breathlessly for the new Michael Jackson
commercial you're like the 92nd spot it
was such a big deal and there was so
many acts in the 80s who were linked
with you know haulin oats and Pontiac
and Kenny Rogers Dole pineapple because
when I see that that sandy white beard
all I want to do is I have a new client
pineapple ya know that became an
important way for a lot of musicians to
get new music out there through
commercials and have their tumors
supported and makes them scratch and you
said in your book you cannot
underestimate the importance of MTV MTV
launched in 1981 and it was music
driving visuals and this was this was a
total shift and an ownership of
advertising and music and culture by
youth completely so explain that like
what was happening at the time and and
what has been the influence well people
in the industry you know they were used
to music you know sort of underlying or
you know being the foundation for furn
for an ad they and with an MTV they came
to realize that oh you know music and
can drive the visuals it's not the other
way around and the idea that music could
play you know an even more powerful role
in commercials and not just as an
emotional underpinning but as using a
particular kind of music to but to
attract a particular kind of consumer
that became much more prominent in the
in the 80s and after yeah I mean my
adidas Run DMC they were they were
always linked with the deenis and they
wrote the song because they really loved
adidas and adidas was kind of giving him
free stuff but then they they ain't a
huge deal yeah and this is this is one
of most interesting things you talked
about the Nike revolution commercial and
the series of spots using Beatles
revolution because Michael Jackson was
like yeah sure I own the rights go ahead
and have them
and Yoko Ono signed off on it but the
band was furious
yeah the the surviving members were very
unhappy but but they didn't own the
rights of their own music anymore so
yeah there wasn't much they could do
they sued Nike and it was settled out of
court and Nike pulled that ad but that
was a major shift because if the Beatles
were gonna let their music be used they
didn't but a lot of people thought that
they were letting their music be used in
commercials and that changed a lot of
things it created panic and you know
this notion of selling out was was huge
in the 90s and you know there were a lot
of bands who just wouldn't be caught
dead and you know music consumers who
would be very disappointed with the rise
of alternative music if their bands
actually sold out you know Nirvana and
Pearl Jam would have never sold write
their music to Nike or McDonald's or
anything like that
god forbid nowadays is there such a
thing as selling out I don't think so I
don't I don't think my son I don't think
my my students care about it at all when
I started teaching in the 90s they cared
a lot like I say you know in the height
of the grunge movement we might it was
very clear my students thought you know
a band is a sellout if they appear on
MTV sorry
it was really tough it was it was a
dynamic that took over the network for a
few years yeah you know during MTV doing
a commercial or signing to a major label
that may do sellout and you know this
students are the same age today they
don't they don't seem to care and I
don't think that they are less political
I just think they have a more complex
notion of what constitutes selling out I
think I think I think for them you know
if a band gets too popular you know I
think it's not really selling out but
then you know they'll turn their
attention doesn't somebody else yeah but
I think they have conceptions of what
selling out is but it's not what it was
in the 90s it's very different no and
now it's such a different era and you
know I think it's great because not only
do consumers have control over the means
of production I mean you can literally
create your own music with limited
technology and resources but you can
also consume it in any way you want
whether it's iTunes and YouTube and you
know you said you can't overstate the
impact of MTV it can the same be said
for YouTube and iTunes
maybe not YouTube yet my students use a
lot but you know to make it I mean what
matters I think to young people is that
the music is made portable you know so
they can have it on their device all the
time all of your music all of the time
on your phone yep and you know you can
do that with YouTube but it's more
cumbersome than if then if you're using
iTunes or you know Spotify or one of
these kinds of streaming services I
think they they use it you know like at
home on the computers but for them I
think what really matters is having
everything instantly available so that
they can you know access whatever music
they want whenever they want including
during my lectures I think and
commercials now break bans yep and I
want you to talk about the relationship
between DVRs and music because people
conceivably don't have to sit through
any commercials at all commercials have
to be so compelling so is this actually
the best medium for bands to get their
music out there well after the
Communications Act of 1996 which made it
possible for you know basically the
monopolization of radio I mean you know
single corporation can own every rock
station in LA if I wanted to that made a
lot harder for music musicians to get
radio airplay because you know the
single entity would just streamline all
of its playlists or standardize all of
his playlists and then all of a sudden
really after 1996 it was a lot harder
for bands to get on the air
and that was why musicians became much
more willing to let their music be used
in TV commercials or they sought to get
their film or the music put in films or
in TV shows which is why you see so much
of that nowadays but at the same time
you have the rise of the DVR right so
now it's I think it's probably even
harder for musicians you know to to get
their music out there because if they're
relying on getting their music in the
commercial people may skip through it so
the measure of success today it might
have been you know getting in a couple
of commercials you know getting a song
or two in a couple of hit TV shows maybe
you put in a film now I think you know
it matters less being put in the
commercial because you just don't know
if people are gonna see it
and your book is called the sounds of
capitalism do you like capitalism
if it's managed like they do easy you
know like they do in Western Europe and
which which we don't yeah we need we
need high-speed rail for music you know
I think you know in the 50s and 60s when
our economy was booming and and the
government you know strongly regulated
capital American capitalism I think it
worked very well I mean now with you
know free-market policies and
deregulation policies you know we've
seen what happens the economy tanked in
2007 we're still struggling to recover
and that's because the government is
playing it was going so well because I
have to tell you the deregulation of
culture taking music back from major
labels a smaller axis reaching larger
audiences through you know first myspace
and now Facebook social media it's been
fantastic and I think any government
regulation would have totally destroyed
that creativity but if you're working
musician it's the fact is it's a lot
harder to make a living than it used to
be if you're a non working musician it's
a lot harder it's a lot harder for
janitors to make a living it's a lot
harder for everybody and some could make
the case it's because we're overtaxed
and over-regulated and you know if the
pre-market were able to prevail as it
should in the arts and music especially
you know the best stuff makes it way it
makes its way out there and now there is
greater means for people to consume
great music and even mediocre music
maybe but you know musicians who have
their music on Spotify make a fraction
of a cent for each song paid they're not
then I'm making a living out that music
is free and the way bands make money now
is they go out and play shows you know
they they sell merchandise if they can
yeah and you know labels aren't making I
mean the consolidation of the music
industry I think you could see the
parallel between that and
advertising yeah it's been very hard on
musicians this hasn't been hard on the
executive it's been hard on the musician
oh no no I'll show you a dozens of
people that I knew who had great jobs
and handsome expense accounts in the 90s
when record companies were thriving who
are now Realtors yeah no those jobs
don't exist anymore
yeah but it's you know I mean there's
been a trend towards monopolization
which has heard the musicians horribly I
mean you know Walmart basically not now
controls the distribution of recordings
by their music on iTunes and by the way
iTunes is the best way for music lovers
to find other stuff that they want to
see because based on what they buy you
know I mean that's the pre-market
working right there okay.we well if if
you still somebody wants to buy a
physical recording then you have to then
whatever Walmart charges for a
distribution you know stores support
your local record store well might still
do distributing to them unless it's a
used record store which I still support
Amen you and I both tim taylor thank you
very much thank you all right well thank
you for joining us remember to check
reason.com for more live events for
reason TV